News investigation has found Google is
getting advertising agencies to create
comparison websites all to give the
illusion of fair competition once
certified operator says the sites are
made to look like the real thing but
aren't actually designed to be used for
shopping it's our technology
correspondent roland band for the
endless hunt for the perfect deal
searching for the brand the fit and of
course the cheapest price online where
shelf space is infinite it should be
even easier in fact it's far more
difficult because of this box who's in
it and why they're there
Sky News has discovered what's
underneath Google's latest change you
might not have noticed but in Europe
Google is looking slightly different
before all these ads at the top is to
say by Google but now some new names
have come up click on the image and
you'll get taken straight to the
advertiser same as normal but if you
click on the name you'll go to one of
Google's 90 plus certified comparison
shopping services and when you do that
you'll find they don't work quite how
you'd expect
these new sites give the illusion of a
thriving marketplace and are supposed to
function according to Google guidelines
which say they should be able to search
and sort products by consumer experts
say the comparison shopping services
don't live up to their name it's a
nonsense this whole site is a gem I
don't know what this is in all honesty
looks like a blog it looks like
somebody's just gone I like hats I like
t-shirts I like film posters there they
are almost all of googles comparison
shopping services a run by ad agencies
the co-founder of one ad firm told us
what his site was really for high street
one is not designed for people to come
on and shop it's not what we call a
shopping destination it's literally a
website set up so people like people
such as ourselves can pass on benefits
to agencies and retailers Google is
encouraging our agencies to build si
by offering hefty discounts for
retailers who used that route for their
ads it's an advertising system that
looks like a price comparison tool so
it's almost like they're kind of fake
price comparison sites in a way we could
call them that yeah the timing is
significant because Google is being
monitored by the European Commission
which find it last year for
anti-competitive behavior a Google
spokesperson told Sky News Google's
shopping complies with the european
commission's order we give all
comparison shopping services the same
opportunity to show ads from merchants
on Google search results page as we give
to Google shopping we spent many days
actually being grilled by potential
customers in that very meteor Adam
achieve on wrath disagree they brought
the case against Google to the European
Commission and one they don't believe
Google is playing fair if the Commission
doesn't intervene Google is pretty
openly thumbing its nose at the
Commission Google will be given a green
light to continue to roll these
practices out into all these other
search verticals like local search and
travel services job search so those will
cease to exist in any real way and
instead you'll just have Google
advertisements at the top and then who
knows even beyond that into retail
itself you know even companies like
Amazon are ultimately vulnerable to
these same manipulative practices
shopping is the first great test of
Google's power when one firm controls
the world's flow of information its
neutrality matters for everyone
rolling on top Sky News